salut a tous un bon soir chantal nous
allons commencer cette nouvelle édition
d europe par l'événement de l'été
l'événement de l'été qui avait lieu le
20 juillet au parc des sports de l'ouest
à nice avec bien sûr la venue des
rolling stones et ça je dois dire que
c'est quelque chose vous savez les
rolling stones qui revenait sur la côte
d'azur après six ans d'absence
un jeu puisque la dernière fois c'était
le 13 de jouan 76 si je ne m'abuse six
en six ans ouais alors les rolling
stones certains les ont trouvé un petit
peu essoufflé il faut dire que tiennent
bien encore le choc encore là pour
réaliser quand même comme si mick jagger
il a 40 ans tu t'étais l'abattoir
c'est un choix le musette ou les rolling
stones